si si un rat qui rentre chez vous on a
un truc facile c'est une plaque
autocollante donc on la place tout
simplement si vous si vous voulez tester
c'est horrible
bah ouais mais bon euh
de crise cardiaque finir par le cœur
s'emballe et finir par maurica
excuse-moi de parler 2 minutes non mais
il mord plus rapide je suis ton ami
horrible
tout simplement hop
et ça marche encore ça
c'est redoutable maintenant dans la la
[__] ça marche toujours
mais il sait maintenant l'oral ça fait
des années qu'on lui fait ça on est
intelligent mais on met des on met des
spray on met des choses on met des
appâts alors là c'est la c'est une
espèce de nourriture qui sent d'accord
et donc il y va quoi il se dit pas c'est
chelou souvent les rats comment ils sont
tellement intelligents ils envoient les
enfants où les personnes âgées en
explorateur et souvent ce qu'on attrape
c'est la Nièvre
infini par une crise cardiaque mais
c'est sur la colle c'est quoi donc là on
le met ça comme ça on met ça là il passe
comme ça il passe souvent on le met à
côté d'un mur d'accord en fait ils longe
les murs il voit mal en fait il sent
bien tout ça qui sortent avec en ce
moment avec les poubelles qui sentent
bien donc on le met à côté d'un mur sur
son lieu de passage éventuellement on
met quelques graines un peu de
nourriture quelques appâts et il va
aller dessus et hop il est collé c'est
terminé ah ouais c'est fini comme il est
collé juste avec ça là ça c'est costaud
ça hein vous pouvez mettre le doigts
donc il reste comme ça le Mushkin il est
cool après ouais non il se débat
s'arracher un membre non franchement
c'est atroce elles sont puissantes
peuvent faire chier non plus hein après
on a des choses tu voulais pas on n'a
pas été chez lui nous ouais non mais
Cyril faut pas faire la promotion de ça
franchement
après il y a
les raticides donc les raticides c'est
simple on va les mettre dans des boîtes
sécurisées hop on les met donc ça c'est
pour une souris c'est plus petit mais on
a des plus grosses pour les rats il
rentre il va il va manger du produit et
donc ça ils se sont pas bien et au bout
de 3 jours il meurent en fait voilà
horrible quand il reste deux trois jours
dedans il meurt au bout de largement il
meurt pas dans la boîte il sent pas bien
il va mourir à l'extérieur c'est ça chez
vous ça le problème générale
après c'est aussi empoisonné
généralement le rail meurt pas sur place
et ça c'est producteur justement pour
les animaux
chat mon chat et bouffe une souris qui
est sorti après avoir bouffé le poison
c'est pour savoir qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur le chat déjà je suis pas sûr que
votre votre chat de domestique qui va
manger la souris pas sûr mais mais si
moi en fait monsieur vous êtes quand
même là à une heure de grande écoute là
vous fait vraiment vous dites n'importe
quoi
non mais au bout d'un moment ça m'énerve
tout le monde sait qu'on est sur une
émission de très très grande écoute vous
pouvez pas dire ça parce que si mon
voisin bête veut empoisonner enfin le
Raoul la souris chez lui et que moi j'ai
un chat à deux maisons et que mon chat
bouffe cette souris là
pas du tout vous connaissez pas vous
connaissez pas le dosage vous connaissez
pas vous connaissez pas c'est pas pareil
je te jure pour un chat c'est pas pareil
parce qu'ils ont bouffé
il paraît que les rats se sont habitués
maintenant au ratissides bien sûr
en fait si vous voulez quand vous allez
dans le grand commerce vous allez dans
les supermarchés vous achetez des
produits les produits sont pas
suffisamment dosés en fait donc mais
nous les produits professionnels donc il
faut un diplôme pour pouvoir les
utiliser les manipuler et les mettre en
place ça fonctionne très bien donc ça
sert à rien d'aller dans les magasins
tout ce qui est insecticide dans les
magasins non seulement c'est pas assez
efficace et c'est assez dangereux il y a
eu des études il y a ma mère qui me dit
papa un truc infaillible pour les rats
apparemment il veut bosser avec vous euh
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a un
appartement par où ils arrivent alors
ça peut être plein de choses ça peut
être il peut varier par les
canalisations il suffit un tout petit
peu de jeu autour la canalisation on
sait qu'on met ce que j'appelle de la
maille de fer autour comme celle-ci
gratte ça le tue en fait ou alors ils
peuvent arriver par le toit il grimpe il
descendent par la toiture il peut
arriver en déguisé en Père Noël par la
cheminée
une maison ça arrive
extrêmement prudent sur l'hygiène on
limite les rats parce que voilà votre
très bonne remarque alors conseil numéro
de nourriture
si on a un jardin un balcon il faut pas
enlever les miettes et cetera comment on
secoue la nappe c'est ça qui va attirer
les rongeurs alors il y a un ami à moi
qui me dit également coucou Cyril c'est
Benjamin moi c'est grâce à ses plaques
collantes que j'ai tué plusieurs rats et
sans ça ça aurait été impossible chez
moi et voilà il a vécu un enfer avec les
rat voilà ça c'est ça c'est qu'on qu'on
veut piéger un rat de rame après si on
veut vraiment on a vraiment un niche
chez soi on est obligé de passer par des
par des produits mon père vous savez ce
qu'il dit voilà ma mère me disent qu'il
fait mon père en fait il met il met un
truc il met du plâtre du sucre et un peu
d'eau
et on laisse travailler c'est un mur en
20 minutes
et
magnifique et donc non non mais là parce
qu'on parlait des rats parce qu'il y a
pas que les reins hein beaucoup beaucoup
de beaucoup d'insectes en ce moment
alors en ce moment il y a aussi de
nombreux insectes regardez cet extrait
regardez dans la chambre
rien n'y fait quand elle tire le frigo
par exemple
en plus des meubles cassés
c'est une véritable scène d'horreur
les blattes ne sont pas les seules
nuisibles à s'inviter dans le lit de
l'étudiante il y avait plein de punaises
et tout et s'il y a plus de lumière ils
vont te piquer et ça va faire des traces
ça va te gratter et tout alors oui les
punaises de lit c'est terrible
pour Bakary Julia c'est tous les soirs
le même spectacle dans le local à
poubelle le ballet des rats ils sortent
de partout et impose aux étudiants une
discipline sportive d'un nouveau genre
avec un lancer maîtrisé
ils disent stratégie acrobatiques mettre
un pied au sol ici c'est assez risqué et
périls
pour pas me faire mordre les reins ça me
dégoûte vraiment je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas rentrer dans là c'est la porte
de l'enfer pour moi je ne peux pas
rentrer j'y arrive pas alors
par exemple quand il y a beaucoup de
comme ça on va pas mettre des trucs
comme ça c'est si on a un mais comment
on fait comme ça c'est là où on va
mettre plein de postes partout et on va
mettre beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des
redondissides des trucs comme ça on
arrive on a d'autres systèmes on a des
boîtes on peut capturer jusqu'à une
quarantaine de rats il rentre dedans
c'est un pote à moi aussi
il m'a dit il m'a dit il m'a parlé de la
boîte c'est ça il se noie à l'intérieur
en fait il rentre il se noie il se noie
dans la boîte ah mais il y en a
plusieurs ah ça peut on peut en mettre
plein ouais
ils ont plein de cafards plein de
punaises il y a un vrai problème
quand on est locataire est-ce qu'on peut
demander aux propriétaires ça lui de
payer de la dératisation ça dépend ça
dépend ça dépend du nuisible ouais une
intervention ça coûte environ dans les
300 euros ça dépend des nuisibles en
général quand c'est des rongeurs oui
c'est plutôt le propriétaire 14 à payer
si c'est des punaises généralement c'est
le locataire qui les a ramené lors d'un
voyage ou autre donc là c'est plutôt le
locataire qui va payer oui l'américaine
oui ça m'est arrivé d'être à l'étranger
et j'étais dans un logement qui avait
des punaises de lit et du coup il y en
avait sur tous mes habits j'ai dû tout
mettre au pressing mais des deux valises
énormes comment on peut savoir quand on
rentre dans un hôtel un logement si vous
affecté ou pas il faut demander
typiquement moi c'est ce que vous êtes
là
vous regardez moi je fais tout le temps
ça de je donne un hôtel vous enlevez les
draps vous regardez le matelas dans les
coutures s'il y a des points noirs ou
des taches de sang ou vous le verrez
tout de suite quoi
les points noirs des punaises en fait
ouais d'accord et le son de des pilotes
que les gens ont écrasé en fait
on peut avoir des œufs sous les semelles
de chaussures et
elles adorent aller au cinéma parce que
les sièges sont en tissu et qu'elle se
fixent sur les tissus ouais tout à fait
on a déjà intervenu au cinéma pour faire
des traitements anti punaises de lit ça
arrive régulièrement qui en est vrai
donc faut se protéger au cinéma il faut
mettre un k-way ou alors mais pas de sac
par terre ou autre quoi ah ouais il faut
pas il faut pas y aller en slip quoi
est-ce qu'il y a une solution préventive
pour jamais avoir de punaises de lit bah
pour les punaises c'est quoi les
punaises
qui ressemblent à ça
qui se nourrissent avec le sang humain
qui peuvent tenir sans se nourrir
pendant 18 mois donc c'est des
guerrières quoi c'est quoi et après ils
viennent te sucer la nuit elle chante
quand on dort en fait la température du
corps elle augmente
et donc du coup la température du corps
augmente on met du dioxyde de carbone
elle sente qu'on dort elles viennent
nous piquer ah ouais et quoi elle est
donc ça fait mal les gens ont des
boutons et tu veux que je te dise moi un
jour je dans un hôtel je te jure que
c'est vrai si vous regardez il y avait
un copain à moi Jérôme Jérôme je te jure
que c'est vrai on dort dans le même dans
le même lit je te le jure que c'est vrai
c'est vraiment c'est la chèvre il se
réveille le matin il est comme ça je
suis j'ai pas eu une piqûre comment ça
se fait c'est comme les moustiques qui
sont piqués donc ils sont pas piqués
elle aimait pas les magasins
est-ce que ça transmet des maladies les
punaises bah les punaises justement ça
tranchaient pas de maladie contrairement
aux rongeur ou à d'autres insectes ou
les moustiques c'est pas dangereux
comment on fait alors on va vous donner
des conseils pour vous débarrasser des
nuisibles dans un instant mais c'est
vrai que et les les les cafards aussi il
y en a de plus en plus vous faites c'est
vrai que même là franchement cafard et
punaise de lit c'est le art c'est le
fléau ouais bah de nous nous justement
on a des tubes comme ça c'est du gel
professionnel qu'on va mettre dans des
on met des points sur des endroits
stratégiques typiquement il se cache
toujours là où c'est chaud humide et
obscur typiquement derrière le frigo sur
le moteur etc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui va là-bas qui va là-bas
il faut que ça soit noir ouais ils
aiment bien ouais vraiment donc ils vont
tous comme si toutes les 1000 et cafards
ils arrivent pourquoi ils aiment le noir
le café bah c'est l'heure c'est l'heure
c'est leur environnement donc
généralement on les voit quand quoi
quand on rentre dans la cuisine la nuit
pour aller chercher à boire à manger ou
autre on allume la lumière et boum c'est
là où on tombe sur lesquelles
toi chez toi sans déconner
invasion de cafards mais si et je les ai
eus avec un truc on dégoupille comme une
grenade et ça pulvérise partout et après
on peut habiter pendant une semaine
voilà on a un peu exagéré quand vous
êtes répartir une semaine mais c'est 5
heures après ouais ouais en fait moi toi
alors et donc non en fait voilà c'est
quoi ce truc là qu'il a dit là c'est pas
bien fumigène c'est un fumigène ce que
j'en ai rien là-dedans j'ai pas de
fumigène mais c'est un complément ce qui
marche en fait on a plusieurs cas des
fois on va chez les gens ça arrive on
voit des centaines de cafards voilà
vraiment là là on fait sortir tout le
monde on pulvérise les et c'est la
première chose quand il y a une
infestation on va dire normal là on met
du gel voilà c'est du gel c'est ça qui
fonctionnent extrêmement ils reviennent
plus après non après c'est terminé
maintenant si vous êtes dans un immeuble
ou ce qui est très infesté je pourrais
pas vous empêcher d'avoir les cafards
des voisins qui reviennent par contre il
reste actif environ 3 à 6 mois donc
quand ils vont venir ils vont mourir
rapidement d'accord et donc un moment il
y a pas un qui leur dit il va pas là-bas
euh
le plus intelligent c'est pas comme les
rongeurs
c'est facile à voir pour nous un cafard
c'est un énorme quelque part c'est comme
les fourmis c'est pas des choses c'est
pas ouf quoi c'est pas c'est pas
préventif pour les punaises de lit sur
mon matelas qu'est-ce qu'on doit mettre
alors ça existe des housses anti
punaises etc etc maintenant la seule
chose les pileux c'est très compliqué
faut être vigilant d'accord car si vous
si vous êtes vraiment si vous avez un
doute quand vous partez en voyage vous
revenez vous avez tout laver à 60 ou au
sèche-linge ou passer un nettoyeur
vapeur dessus quoi mais ou alors vous
pouvez coller par exemple du du scotch
double face sur les pieds du lit si on a
le seront forcément attraper vous voyez
il paraît quand on fait ça ou la
soucoupe d'eau pour éviter qu'elle
remonte par le biais exactement la
punaise elle vient au plafond et à cela
pour tomber sur le lit c'est vrai non
non
qui me racontait ça se met en route là
chez elles arrivent sur le lit
mais bien sûr est-ce que c'est vrai que
l'explosion en ce moment de la présence
des punaises de lit et du notamment au
fait que les ventes de vêtements
d'occasion
bien sûr c'est vrai bien sûr l'occasion
c'est généralement les gens ils nous
appellent aujourd'hui vous avez fait
quoi récemment ah acheter un meuble
d'occasion j'ai acheté des vêtements
d'occasion j'ai acheté de
l'électroménager d'occasion et on sait
très bien que dans l'électroménager
d'occasion il peut y avoir des cafards
des choses si vous trouvez un matelas en
bas de chez vous dans la rue quelqu'un
qui a acheté on dit vous dites pas c'est
sympa c'est gratuit un matelas non c'est
c'est franchement très risqué quoi donc
après on se retrouve avec des punaises
et c'est une tasse c'est galère sur tous
les gens ils mettent du temps à s'en
rendre compte il faut il faut pas
forcément appelé un professionnel tout
de suite donc forcément ça marche ça les
produits sont pas assez forts qu'est-ce
qu'il attire les punaises de lit les
punaises de lit généralement non elles
sont elles sont là en voyage cinéma
comme on a dit etc on arrive dans un
hôtel alors on fait tous les hôtels on a
des clients c'est des 5 étoiles comme
des comme des petits etc voilà il y a
tout type d'hôtel merde maintenant les
cinq étoiles ont tendance à réagir très
vite et très bien parce qu'ils mettent
plus de moyens mais sinon il y en a
partout quoi voilà il a partout et donc
on arrive sur le on arrive en vacances
on fait pas gaffe on met la valise sur
le lit hop on nous on défait ses
affaires et la Bible les punaises elles
s'amuse elle rentre et c'est parti c'est
fini et après les punaises tu les as
tout le temps non après si c'est bien
traité en deux semaines c'est réglé quoi
mais bon c'est les gens ça peut on a des
gens ils me disent ça fait 8 9 ans
qu'ils ont depuis
[Musique]
il y avait des cafards et
on avait toujours des cafards qui se
promenaient et tout et donc au bout d'un
moment j'ai appelé la propriétaire qui
est un peu rechignée et tout à venir
donc ça a duré vraiment plusieurs
semaines et après quelqu'un est venu il
nous a mis des gouttes un peu partout
plus la femme le fameux
ouais et après du coup je les ai
nettoyés je les ai balayé je les ai bien
mis à la poubelle et tout simplement
j'ai constaté quelque chose je peux
l'expliquer sur le cafard j'ai fait un
truc il y en avait sur le mur de la
salle de bain du coup je les contré
comme ça ah il a essayé de partir je
l'ai rencontré comme ça il a commencé à
s'exciter
et donc ma conclusion de la personne à
qui j'étais à côté j'ai dit ok on va les
tuer c'est qu'à faire parce qu'on peut
pas vivre comme ça mais je voulais juste
t'expliquer que même un cafard aussi
petit et aussi nuisible soit-il à une
conscience parce que tout ce qui voulait
le cafard c'était partir pour pouvoir
être nouveau en paix et j'ai trouvé ça
très intéressant parce que même un
insecte à une conscience donc monsieur
quand vous venez ici et que tu pourras
mammifère vous faites la promotion de de
produits
ces trucs de colle ils vont se bouffer
les pâtes pour pouvoir se tire bien sûr
il y a des pièges bien sûr
les mouches que nos grands-pères il y
avait voilà c'est la même chose
exactement
pour les moustiques je savais pas ça
j'ai appris ça dans les îles s'ils
viennent jamais sur le le blanc parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont se faire
repérer
si tu as un pote qui a un t-shirt noir
il va avoir tous les moustiques vont
venir sur lui parce qu'ils sont cachés
ils savent qu'on les repères pas sur le
noir là faut les refaire sur le blanc
c'est intéressant
et tu sais tu sais ce qui passe par la
tête d'un moustique qui s'écrase sur ton
pare-brise 200 km le fion ça lui passe
par la tête
Castaldi ce matin il est encore vu des
rats en bas de chez lui
c'est pas des rats
et il a raté voilà c'est l'histoire de
sa vie euh c'est ça j'ai vraiment
vulnérables
à chaque fois que tu prenais les photos
j'ai vu les rats tu vois des rats je
vois pas la Tour Eiffel à 2 mètres tu
vas voir
des conneries c'est dégueulasse tu as dû
confondre c'était des pistaches non
10 conseils pour se débarrasser d'une
usines premier conseil attention aux
achats d'occasion vous l'a dit tout à
l'heure ce soir voilà des meubles des
mais comment on sait parce que on reçoit
le meuble à la maison on fait quoi pour
savoir s'il est faut faire gaffe déjà
quand c'est un habit si on peut que tous
les habits ne se la fasse 60 mais dès
qu'on reçoit quelque chose d'occasion on
lave à 60 ou au sèche-linge même si
c'est une armoire
puisque ça Charente un petit coup de
nettoyeur vapeur ça serait idéal 60 le
meuble
si on peut attention les 59 60
fleurs ce genre de choses ça tire les
moustiques là vous avez des nids
moustiques et vous êtes mal quoi moi je
déteste les moustique les moustiques je
crois qu'il y a rien de pire que le
moustique qui passe à côté de ton
oreille la nuit tu sais pourquoi faire
c'est pour te faire changer de place
parce qu'elle a pas trouvé un endroit
idéal pour te piquer donc il vient faire
et hop là qui vient de piquer là c'est
des [__] les moustiques
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul truc où j'ai une astuce
justement je fais pas comme ça parce que
dans le moustique il part et après il
revient ça ça fait que retarder le truc
je dors comme ça je laisse le moustique
s'approcher se poser et quand je sens
que c'est pâtes
et puis il reste des gens sur l'autre
joue toi
parce que il se il veut
et quand il y a c'est pas de taxes comme
ça mais il te pire parce que là pour
sentir les pâtes et tout vous êtes sûr
que c'était pas
il arrive en voiture
c'est Gandhi qui avait dit c'est quand
un moustique se pose sur beaucoup et que
vous vous rendez compte que la violence
n'est pas toujours une solution
c'est très dense
il a surtout mal à raconter
fenêtre ouverte et lumière ne font pas
bon ménage on le sait bien sûr
avec les rats à Paris nous laissaient
pas les connaître au rez-de-chaussée
tu laisses les fenêtres ouvertes il y a
un rat qui peut arriver en ce moment il
y en a beaucoup dehors donc il faut
faire attention c'est fou c'est fou ça
il y a plus de cambrioleur qui passe que
Dracon
il y a des rats cambrioleur aussi
[Musique]
au quatrième sans ascenseur tu crois
vraiment que Laura quand il y a des
danseurs il arrive quand même
[Rires]
moi troisième et toi bah vas-y je te
dépose non mais tu es con ou quoi
est-ce que c'est vrai que les reins
attaquent
génital pareil que normalement elle aura
peut te sauter au les clients ont pas
raconté ça je te jure
que c'est vrai non non
mais je te jure que c'est vrai parce
qu'il peut te jure c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit c'est des mecs qui chassaient les
rats les chasseurs de rats il faut faire
attention en tout cas qu'on est aux
toilettes ils peuvent sortir
aux toilettes il y a un rat qui peut
sortir tu vas voir ça va te faire tout
drôle tu vas en chier
donc voilà voilà voilà je vous dis voilà
le rat il arrive comme ça et je peux te
dire et si Laura te bouffe le cul tu vas
voir
alors attention à vos matelas si on vous
l'a dit surtout en voyage vérifier que
mon matelas ça prend 15 secondes vous
vérifiez vous aurez pas de punaise noire
ou encore des taches de sang qui
témoigneraient du passage de nuisibles
très bien voilà après voilà exactement
le scotch double face et votre meilleur
ami quand vous rentrez chez vous vous
pouvez en mettre comme ça si jamais vous
en avez attrapé vous le saurez tout de
suite en fait ce qu'il faut c'est bien
parce que j'ai pas compris sur les pieds
du du lit de votre lit c'est-à-dire que
s'il y a des punaises que vous allez
ramener elles vont forcément ou qu'elle
soit donc forcément venir vers votre lit
grimper et donc vous allez en attraper
vous serez tout de suite que vous avez
des punaises dans le scotch double face
on en met sur le truc
vous enroulez votre ça marche bien c'est
un outil ça a pas de tuer tout le
problème mais ça c'est un outil pour
savoir qu'on en a exactement et après
vous nous appelez
protéger vos animaux ce que disait ouais
ils peuvent
c'est souvent eux qui ramène tout ce qui
est plus ce genre de chose
très souvent ça vient de la
[Rires]
une parure le chat donc ça c'est pas bon
ça d'accord très bien
attention au fond des paquets alors
c'est quoi ça quel paquet vous parlez
déjà eu des mythes par des titres des
petits papillons qui volent chez soi
dans les vêtements
des Français ont déjà eu des nuisibles
dans les cinq dernières années
donc limite souvent on les a on les
attrape qu'on achète des paquets au
supermarché très souvent et ça arrive à
je vous dis ça arrive quasiment tout le
monde et donc regardez un petit
rapidement sur les paquets de farine le
pâtes s'il y a pas un nid au fond du
paquet et quand on fait quoi alors il y
a des choses par exemple tu le donnes à
un autre mec tu le mets danses pas qui
tu mets dans le quartier là aucun vous
avez des plaques par exemple il y a des
phéromones donc ça va attirer les mâles
et ils vont venir se coller directement
sur les plaques mais comment on fait
comment on voit sur les paquets de
farine s'il y a des nid on le voit on le
voit il y a des traces et des des vers
des choses mais on voit ouais clairement
le toile d'araignées aussi
embêtant parce qu'on voit des petits
papillons on se dit c'est pas grand
chose mais ça continue ça continue ça
continue
après il y a les mythes sur tous les
murs
il faut traiter rapidement il faut
traiter rapidement c'est ça
l'armoire de sa femme il ouvre un mec à
poil dans la chambre de sa femme dit
vous faites quoi bah dit je chasse les
mythes
le délire vous chassez les mites à poil
et je regarde il fait un [__] un monde
es
non mais chez toi tu as quoi mais oui
des mythes comme ça
sortie des comme ça
Édouard aussi oui
mais il y en a moins maintenant mais
c'est vrai que dans la courette dans la
courette de la partie commune
grosse boîte exactement et passe à côté
les boîtes sont toujours vides pourquoi
parce que moi qui a des boîtes il y a
pas un rat dans les boîtes donc c'est
normal
quoi les rails
et pourquoi ils sont et pourquoi il
rentre pas dans en boîte
[Rires]
fion qui change le plus rapidement de
sexe
surtout pendant le coït oui c'est toi
allez allez
[Applaudissements]
ne pas laisser traîner de la nourriture
chez vous
avez une poubelle vous laissez un sac au
diable j'irai le jeter deux mains non
vous avez une poubelle vous mettez le
couvercle vous avez la vaisselle qui
traîne dans l'évier non non il faut
absolument vous la nettoyer et de temps
en temps vous tirez votre frigo et vous
nettoyez en dessous parce que là-dessus
on voit souvent énormément comment il
fait le gâteau dans ta cuisine le rat il
sent comme ça de là-bas
un cafard il est dans l'immeuble il va
sentir un appartement où il y a ou c'est
voilà il a senti il va il va il va
rentrer en fait la propreté c'est le
conseil numéro 1 quoi bon ben j'ai été
mort j'ai une question à vous poser
là-dessus parce que souvent nous ce
qu'on fait c'est que on laisse de la
nourriture à la fenêtre pour pas
encombrer le frigo
et là et là évidemment là tu as des
pigeon tout ça
me dit tiens on va aller chez Gilles il
y a deux camembert Charleroi à la
fenêtre on va se régaler tu vois mais tu
es où je pense qu'il y a pas mal de
traitements à faire chez vous
vous achetez des bocaux en verre ou des
Tupperware enfin les boîtes en plastique
des aliments dedans ça c'est parfait
c'est super d'accord je vais faire ça
parce qu'on a des plats sur le
bocal non mais je vais le dire à ma
compagne que je suis content qu'elle
vous entend aussi elle va vous entendre
et là je vais lui dire on arrête les
plats qui ne sont pas emballés sur le
rebord des fenêtres bien sûr
le cafard j'ai pris comme ça et énorme
comme ça effectivement
je l'ai mis dans les toilettes et le et
là je vois
la nager
ah dernier conseil même dehors il faut
faire attention alors c'est quoi ça
maintenant il faut faire attention donc
ça veut dire ne laissez pas de miettes
après avoir mangé dans votre jardin ou
balcon ça tienne oui c'est pareil ça ça
risque alors le problème aussi qu'on a
vu des fois au rez-de-chaussée on a
beaucoup de gens les gens au-dessus
aucune étoile balance la nappe ça tombe
ou alors on mange on fait un petit
déjeuner dans dans le jardin on va pas
forcément nettoyer tout de suite là il y
a des mecs qui vont tomber on va mettre
les miettes par terre c'est ça donc il
faut toujours c'est le conseil numéro 1
c'est la propreté
mort je pense que tu es cuit